monsieur maurice rowland marignane dans
les bouches du rhône nous transmet un
reproche et des pénétrations
bravo pour savoureuse au pignon sur rue
nous écrit-il mais pourquoi diable
n'avez vous jamais encore fait un sort
au langage des technocrates et
politiciens qui compliqua plaisir la
langue française pour faire semblant
d'être cultivé au plan de la pensée
rationnelle nous abondons dans votre
sens monsieur rolland à telle enseigne
que gérard pas bio notre spécialiste de
la communication à emprunter pour vous
l'infrastructure routière de l'hexagone
pour rallier nevers à aubenas plaque
tournante de leur région respective et
dans le tissu urbain de ces deux sites
eiffarie l'attenté de désorienter les
carences linguistiques de ses
interlocuteurs et vous allez le voir au
niveau du comics et positivement valable
vous n'êtes pas natif de l'hexagone
monsieur non c'est quoi la région du
lion c'est pas l'hexagone
c'est le talent rhône l'hexagone vous le
mettez ou alors les natifs de l'hexagone
c'est à quel endroit
alors là ça m'échappe à votre avis
l'hexagone qu'est ce que c'est c'est
donc à deux côtés un quoi ronca deux
côtés de côté oui vous êtes sur wii
qu'appelle-t-on le complexe
socioculturel monsieur mais c'est
quelqu'un qui a un complexe parce que il
a l'impression qu'il ne connaît pas
cette chose et puis il a du mal à vivre
en société
l'impasse budgétaire ça vous dit quelque
chose ça fait plaisir
j'habite à neuf et un jour bien entendu
parler de ça fait plusieurs années que
j'habite à nevers je n'ai jamais entendu
parler ces deux courses et s'interpose
militaire l'impasse budgétaire
à votre avis avant ce soit dans les
nouveaux logements du sort fait aux
courlis voyez vous ce qu'est le
recyclage par exemple au moins avoir
arrêté de faire du vélo et puis en
reprendre des années plus tard prendre
ce sport soit pour son plaisir et vous
avez été recyclés vous avez fait du
recyclage
ben oui moi disons que j'arrêtais champs
non mon âge pas j'en ai toujours fait
toujours a plu peut quoi de quoi ni vélo
voyez-vous ce qu est un champ de
perception globale par exemple oui bah
il me semble
terrain qui est un terrain où il peut y
avoir des bêtes dessus on voit même des
fois je suis pas tentation quoi que ce
soit ou le percepteur ceux prélevés sur
un an pour la dessus qu'appelle-t-on les
coordonnées de quelqu'un quand quelqu'un
met une super à chemisier dans les mêmes
coloris et laisser ses coordonnées
qu'est ce que c'est déshabiller
voyez-vous ce qu'était un stéréotype
ouais alors c'est un type qui est
branché car un walkman sur les oreilles
du coude de la musique à canal dans une
oreille l'aude dans l'autre un autre sur
la tête pourquoi stéréotypes alors parce
que c'est la musique la musique stéréo
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle la masse
salariale madame la masse des gens qui
sont pas propres c'est-à-dire qu'ils
n'achètent pas de produits pour se laver
alors comme exemple de masse salariale
qu'est ce que vous auriez
de plus en plus de pouls dans les écoles
de gens qui se laissent aller qui sont
pas rasé qui sont sales
vous dites ça pour moi non pas du tout
non mais moi quand j'entends pas rasé
j'entends qu'ils sont vraiment je vois
partie de la masse salariale
enfin du tout non les gens qui sont
vraiment qu'ils sont vraiment sale